les spécialistes de l'alimentation nous
met de plus en plus en garde contre la
consommation d'aliments ultra
transformer cette semaine je ne sais pas
si vous les avez vus à deux nouvelles
études qui ont paru et qui montre que
ces plats ces éléments là sont
directement liés à l'augmentation de
problèmes de santé même de risque de
décès prématuré on va parler de ses
études avec renault manuguerra gagner
dans notre élection second jour nos
jours alors quand on pense à des
éléments ultra transformer rapidement
pensé aux boissons gazeuses comme on a
vu hot chips mais c'est beaucoup plus
large que ça oui moi même j'ai été
surpris à quel point c'est il ya
beaucoup d'aliments qui rentrent dans
cette catégorie là donc un animal
transformer c'est toute nourriture qui a
subi des changements qu'on ne serait pas
capable de faire quand on est chez soi
donc c'est des aliments qui ont étiré
qui ont traversé des cuissons à très
haute température qui ont beaucoup de
produits additifs beaucoup de sel de
sucre des grands a ajouté c'est les
produits qu'on ne touche chez soi on en
a tous déjà consommé ça peut aller de
soupe en dessous instantanée des viandes
panne et des différents produits
congelés
donc c'est tous des choses qu'on mange
mais le problème c'est que notre
alimentation au complet comme ans est
basé là dessus et au canada on est le
deuxième pays qui en consomment le plus
au monde encore en moyenne un canadien
va consommer 230 kg de produits le treut
transformer chaque année c'est c'est la
moitié des calories dont on a besoin
dans l'année et quand on en mange à ce
point la baisse a pu entraîner des
problèmes de santé et le message dans
ces études là c'est clair c'est que si
on en mange beaucoup en tout cas vous
nous dire et là quel point ça c'est
qu'il ya des risques pour la santé qui
sont associés ouais c'est se mettre dans
le fossé deux études ont montré que sont
venus confirmer ce dont on se doutait
déjà donc que la consommation assez
abusive d'aliments transformés ça peut
entraîner des différents risques donc
deux études qui sont parues cette
semaine dans le british le british
medical journal
une française et une espagnole et les
deux études sont très fortes elles ont
suivi des dizaines de milliers de
personnes pendant plusieurs années ils
ont évalué
qu'est ce que ces personnes à manger et
ils ont suivi leur état de santé en
conséquence ce qu'ils ont la première
c'est la plus celle qui est la plus
importante c'est l'étude française c'est
la plus grande
ont suivi six cent mille personnes
pendant plusieurs années ils ont
remarqué qu'à chaque fois que en moyenne
en tout cas chaque fois qu'une personne
augmenté de 10% sa consommation annuelle
de produits ultra transformer mais ça
s'accompagne d'une hausse de 12% des
risques de développer des maladies
cardiovasculaires
d'un autre côté l'étude espagnole elle a
suivi vingt mille personnes et ont
remarqué qu'il y avait une hausse du
risque de décès de bons liens à
différentes maladies de 62 % chez les
personnes qui consomment 4 portions et
plus de produits transformés chaque jour
comparativement à celles qui en mangent
moins de 2 donc c'est vraiment des
chiffres qui sont quand même assez
impressionnant et d'études ont été très
bien faite aussi est ce que cette eau
cela est considéré comme grave
statistiquement c'est une hausse qui
reste faible mais ce que les chercheurs
ont marqué c'est qu'elle était
extrêmement significative donc même
quand on prenant en compte l'âge des
patients leur leur sexe leur aux
habitudes de vie il y avait toujours ce
lien très fort entre la consommation
d'aliments être transformée et ce qui
est l'état de santé de cette personne là
par contre on a fait ce lien ne sais pas
qu'est ce qui cause le problème on sait
pas qui est ce qui se trouve dans un
animal transformé qui va causer des
problèmes c'est la prochaine étape de ce
lien cause à effet qui reste avec iressa
trouver et à ce que les chercheurs ont
des des hypothèses pas réparation des
pistes il y en a quand même plusieurs on
pense pas que ça rapport avec la qualité
nutritionnelle trith yves des aliments
donc même si les aliments y être
transformé ces pauvre en vitamines ou en
fibres les j'aime pas le 10ème
en fait on n'est pas encore certain
c'est surtout du côté des produits
additifs que l'epa en général que les
personnes veulent que les chercheurs
veulent vérifier
on n'a pas encore de preuves oui le sel
c'est sûr que ça des liens que les
maladies cardiovasculaires quand on en
consomme trop mais côté on essaie de
trouver des quelque chose d'un peu plus
profonde que ce qu'on savait déjà pour
ce qui est des additifs
on n'y a pas d'étude humaine qui montre
encore que c'est un peu ça peut causer
des risques chez l'humain par contre du
côté des études animales beaucoup de
doute donc les chercheurs veulent
creuser plus là dessus et aussi des
risques certaines molécules se mélangent
dans notre corps qu'on mange beaucoup de
produits de produits transformés que des
molécules qui sont sécuritaires
mais une fois dans le corps est ce qu'on
veut dans l'ensemble ce à cause des
risques et puis aussi avoir des
problèmes par exemple du côté des
emballages de plastique différentes
molécules dans le plastique qui n'est
grave
derrière tout ça ça peut causer problème
et c'est pour ça que les chercheurs
demande d'appliquer le principe de
précaution de consommer moins de ces
éléments là et demande au gouvernement
aussi de les rendre plus accessibles et
pour et moins coûteuse pour pas que ce
soit mais de rendre les aliments autre
que louis les fruits et légumes doivent
plus accessible et moins coûteux pour
elles s'opposent les personnes en moyens
qu'ils puissent avoir accès à ces
produits là c'est une bonne salade et
comme on n'a pas merci beaucoup de nous
mais ça fait plaisir en journée